So what I feel free today is a song, a song in the style of George Forme, entitled
When I'm Scanning Websites.
Okay, I'm going to hear this.
Now I go Scanning Websites to earn an honest bond,
For a naughty partner it's an interesting job.
Now it's a job that just seems me, and the sweet user you would leave,
If you could see what I can see.
When I'm Scanning Websites, cause when your site is under pressure,
Cause now I love to make it fresher, and bless those clever folks in Cheshire.
When I'm Scanning Websites, and whose partners fit they work hard,
And they never stop.
It's why they're everybody's favourite, WebScan one-stop shop work.
Now when I scan I like to see, the pants, the crawls crawl for me,
So the bird's tree shows a pin-a-train.
When I'm Scanning Websites, and when my needs want blood prevention,
Require a little more invention, I craft a cheeky path extension.
When I'm Scanning Websites, and when I'm Scanning Websites,
Or a beach ex-knights when I would rather, avoid the upset and the laughter,
Of sitting down and writing Java.
When I'm Scanning Websites, and with hard knocks,
And with hard knocks, when they work hard, they never take a break.
Except for half an hour each day, when we stop and have a cake.
Now when I need to analyse a portfolio of a larger size,
I'll switch to HerbSuite Enterprise.
When I'm Scanning Websites, or if I feel I'd rather see,
Result in my CICV, well then I plug in as the link.
When I'm building websites, it has the hook.
So HerbSuite is my favourite scanning app,
Cause I've used the little r-sites app,
And in a word, they've all been so off-rope.
When I'm Scanning Websites,
When I'm Scanning Websites.